[Music]
we'll switching things over to politics
exclusive inside at the heated races for
governor and senate a new eight news now
the hill emerson college poll focused on
the republican field it shows where
things stand before next month's primary
politics now host john langler looks the
numbers
not what your country can do the ads are
everywhere
a crowded field of republicans jockeying
for position before the june primary it
looks like we've got two clear
front-runners in both the governor's
race and in the senate race spencer
kimball is with emerson college it'll be
interesting to see if they're able to
take it obviously the distance to june
14. a bunch of keyboard cowboys in the
governor's race clark county sheriff joe
lombardo leads in our new bowling he
came in at 32 and a half percent
attorney joey gilbert endorsed by the
nevada gop came in second about 18
points behind former senator dean heller
and north las vegas mayor john lee came
in third and fourth things shift when we
asked undecided republicans where
they're leaning lombardo has a six point
lead over lee followed closely by heller
gilbert comes in fourth if you're going
to see a move on with one of these
candidates this is going to be the time
adam laxalt
i'm sam brown
in the senate gop primary race former
state attorney general adam laxalt's
being challenged by newcomer and wounded
army veteran sam brown brown is endorsed
by the state gop among republican voters
laxalt leads with roughly half of those
polled brown comes in at 27 percent
undecided republicans are also leaning
towards lax salt while brown is around
26 percent no doubt former president
donald trump still looms large within
the gop our poll shows 54 percent of
republicans are more likely to choose
someone endorsed by mr trump he's
already put his support behind lombardo
for governor and laxalt for senate after
june 14th at that point i think you're
going to see those candidates forget who
donald trump is
and say no thank you mr president we
don't need a rally here in nevada we're
good the name recognition and the trump
endorsement are what carrying the day
for those two candidates as you
mentioned the state gop really endorsed
two other candidates
last week and neither one is is in
really competitive position at this
point so to be clear we conducted our
poll of about a thousand
likely republican voters between april
28th and may 2nd the margin of error
plus or minus 3 percent
john langler live local now